how fast can you build a successful
company even that is why I think most
people are not winning I've never
thought of anything besides how slow can
I build something it's speed matters now
yeah okay speed matters I also think
it's why nobody's winning speed is the
devil do you know why everyone's sitting
and analyzing so much because they're
trying to figure out how to do it fast
speed's the [ __ ] devil I've never
wanted fast because I've always sensed
and then now I feel very confident that
I'm right at 46 years old that fast is
what [ __ ] everyone up because you go
into shortcut land and that's just real
talk it just is when you're 20 you're 10
years old 10 years ago and I remember
being 22 and my cousin Bobby being 30
and I thought my cousin Bobby was the
oldest man on Earth so I know how hard
it is when I tell them hey think of this
as a 10-year game they're like [ __ ] you
Gary that feels like forever the problem
is it's why so many 20 year olds lose
it's also back to mental health and all
that it's why they're all so anxious
they want fast to show everyone else
they want and that's really [ __ ] them
up